so now that we're getting into really
the meat of the 2022 midterm elections
we've had some primaries we haven't a
bunch of other primaries coming up
we are getting into the farcical
cringe stage of many of these
candidacies and we're going to look at a
couple of different candidates and ads
today
we're going to start with mehmet oz
mehmet oz is running for senate he's
running in the republican primary in
pennsylvania he's been endorsed by trump
but as we saw yesterday
in some clips from the weekend's rally
many trumpists aren't thrilled with
mehmet oz and one of the reasons that
they're not thrilled with mehmet oz
is that really he has a decade plus
of saying stuff about politics that
aligns more with the democratic than the
republican party i think memit oz is
completely unqualified
he's done quack doctor stuff on tv for
years uh he's dishonest all these
different things
but it is also true that at least some
of his positions historically have lined
up more with the democratic party than
the republican party this includes his
views on uh guns early in the pandemic
he was more aligned with the pro-science
side which was the more left-leaning
side let's be frank and he's recently
had to change a lot of these positions
and he now has a completely
it almost seems satirical ad where he's
firing guns and the thing about this is
the first level of cringe
would be someone running
and in a serious manner
having these views about guns
and doing these types of videos where
they're out on the range firing at clay
pigeons and this type of thing
the second layer of cringe is what oz is
doing which is
it doesn't even seem like it's genuine
he's pandering
with this stuff even though it doesn't
align with the mem at oz that we've
known for a decade so we're going to
look at the ad
and uh if you're not watching if you're
just listening
i will mention that there's a particular
shot
where it sort of looks like oz is
shooting and hitting a clay pigeon
these are like these discs that are
thrown into the air but if you look at
how it's cut it's very obvious that they
filmed him firing the weapon
and then later filmed the clay pigeon
exploding
and it's pretty damn obvious that oz
didn't hit the clay pigeon not that it
matters it's all absurd so let's look at
the ad and then we'll talk about it
my father taught me how to handle my
first gun i taught my son oliver how to
do the same
i've been shooting and hunting my whole
life so when people say i won't support
guns
they're dead wrong
boom
[Music]
other conservatives know that i'm strong
on the second amendment ted nugent rick
perry president trump but our second
amendment is not just about hunting it's
about our constitutional right to
protect ourselves from intruders or an
overly intrusive government so as your
next u.s senator i will fight for our
constitutional rights
yeah
we need the guns to protect ourselves
from an overly intrusive government sort
of like one that says there's no right
to an abortion and states can ban it uh
listen
we have a second amendment
we we have a second amendment period
right
i support
mandatory gun training
licensing
re-licensing mandatory insurance
eliminating the so-called gun show or
boyfriend loophole or whatever they're
calling it these days you got to have a
background check for every transaction
all we have a second amendment and i
support all of that stuff
oz has had a somewhat similar view to
that
for most of his public record
until recently and now it's very clear
that he'll say whatever the hell he has
to in order to try to win a republican
primary and this is very similar to the
trump abortion thing oz pushed
gun safety regulations most of his
public life he wrote op-eds he said we
need to we need gun control
we need to quote stop gun violence we
need to treat shootings as a public
health emergency which i agree with and
then now all of a sudden he's having to
backtrack and find and stake out this
new position remember donald trump was
pro-choice his entire life right he was
68 years old and he had been pro-choice
his entire public life up until that
point
he had no shot at winning the democratic
presidential nomination in 2016 so he
ran as a republican and he had to stake
out a position on abortion that would be
palatable to republicans so trump came
up with this awakening that he had he
knew and
he knew people around him knew
you need a story you need an explanation
as to why you were pro-choice for 68
years and now you are suddenly
anti-choice and trump's story
paraphrased was
he met a kid once i don't remember if
the kid was 12 or 16 at the time
and the kid's mother said to trump you
know
i thought about getting an abortion
and i i decided not to
and the awakening trump had was wow
i like this kid this is a good kid
abortion is bad and now i'm against
abortion for all these religious all
these different reasons that are
completely unbelievable this is kind of
a similar thing which is oz now has to
stake out uh this uh pro
wildly pro-gun position now how is the
prize is this helping him how is the
primary and how is the race going so on
the republican side
oz does appear to be winning although
it's it's within the margin of error on
average oz is ahead of the second place
candidate mccormick by two and a half
and then ahead of the third place
candidate barnett by four points
now it's almost certain
that if mccormick or barnett bowed out
the other one would consolidate a bunch
of that support
and uh might might be able to defeat oz
but that's the way it's looking right
now oz with a slight lead and then over
on the democratic side john fetterman
who is my choice although his debate
performance wasn't very good fetterman
is my choice in pennsylvania he has
opened up on an average
a 31 point lead over the second place
contender conor lamb
so it's almost certainly going to be
fetterman against whoever wins the
republican primary so that's what's
going on there we'll continue to watch
it and uh dr oz used to do surgeries on
people that's uh that's quite a thing
as many of you know i'm a busy person i
don't always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time-consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1
and i'm getting 75 high-quality vitamins
and minerals and my probiotics and it's
all from whole food sources i drink it
in the morning i know i'm good i don't
have to be messing around with different
pills and supplements or whatever or
spend time planning when what time of
day do i need to take each one i just
get it all with one scoop you can put it
in a smoothie you can drink it straight
it tastes great and then i'm just good
for the day it supports gut health and
i'm getting everything that i need and
i'm looking for athletic greens is
giving my audience a free one-year
supply of vitamin d plus five free
travel packs when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below